it's being called britain's summer of
strikes tens of thousands of workers
across different sectors have walked off
the job they want better pay and
conditions to combat record high
inflation will businesses and government
leaders meet their demands this is
inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
workers in the uk have launched some of
their most disruptive industrial action
in years with living costs hitting a
40-year high they want more pay and
better conditions tens of thousands of
transport staff postal employees and
even lawyers have walked off the job and
for the first time in 30 years doc
workers also went on strike at britain's
largest container port trade unions
accused business leaders of putting
profits ahead of workers but the
government says union bosses are holding
the country to ransom
we'll bring in our guests in just a
moment first harry fawcett has more from
felix doe port in the east of england
the world's largest container ship at
britain's largest container port the
everelotte arrived on thursday and
normally would be long gone by now but
strike action by felix does 1900 dock
workers has stopped operations
the unite union says a recently
increased offer of a seven percent pay
rise doesn't keep pace with spiraling
inflation it's seeking a double-digit
raise that it says would share surging
corporate profits 71 million dollars at
last count more equitably with the
workers
now unfortunately we've yet to be
given an offer which we think we can
take back and which reflects our members
aspirations
and talking to our members today and you
know which we're in a position to do as
you can see
we've we've had that
message sent back to us loud and clear
felix though port says it was reminded
in recent days by the bank of england of
the inflationary effects of big pay
rises the port company accuses the union
of using the workers in a national
struggle on average for our workers this
is an extra three and a half thousand
pounds in cash to them each year the
action that they're taking now that
united is making them taken and you
might haven't put this offer to our
workers but the action that united is
making them take is actually going to
take the best part of a thousand pounds
out of their pocket the question is how
far the effects of this shutdown will
ripple through the uk economy the port
says the effects will be manageable
pointing to the lessons learned during
the supply chain disruption of the
pandemic
certainly the ever a lot isn't going
anywhere anytime soon and some industry
analysis suggests other container
shippers are already offloading their
cargo in europe instead of the uk the
union accepts there will be major
disruption and says that it could carry
out further strikes as it seeks what it
says is a fair deal
up the road in ipswich adam scott's
printing and embroidery business relies
on imported materials textiles ink and
vinyl he supports the right to strike
but is worried about further shocks to a
supply chain that's already stretched
and only getting costlier historically
where we'd have maybe
two price rises a year you know sort of
two three percent something like that
we're now looking at you know eight to
ten percent price rises monthly from our
suppliers so it's
a challenging environment for us over
the last
this sunday's cargo at felixstowe was
restricted to day trippers all sides are
settling in for a long wait for this
dispute to be resolved and it's just won
among many a long summer of industrial
action and economic uncertainty isn't
yet over harry fawcett al jazeera felix
stow
well the nationwide strikes have brought
parts of britain's rail network to a
standstill and caused days of
disruptions only one in five trains were
running on thursday and saturday
london's underground transport has been
hit by four 24-hour walkouts this year
that's had a knock-on effect on other
services where there weren't any strikes
including the eurostar criminal lawyers
and rubbish collectors also stopped
working
it's not just the public sector private
companies are also being affected staff
at telecoms giant bt stopped work for
four days at the end of july for the
first time in 35 years amazon warehouse
staff have also staged walkouts and some
proposed strikes have been halted after
pay deals were agreed these include some
by british airways ground staff and
plane refuellers at london's heathrow
airport but other workers are holding
firm postal staff plan action later this
month and teachers and health workers
have hinted at possible walkouts if they
don't get paid deals they consider
acceptable
let's bring in our guests at this point
and all of it all of them are joining us
from london we have stephen cotton he's
the general secretary of the
international transport workers
federation pushpin singh is an economist
at the center for economic and business
research and charles cunningham is the
founder of the public relations agency
trafalgar strategy and former head of
press at the uk prime minister's office
from 2015 to 16 a very warm welcome to
all of you stephen let's start by just
just discussing why all these strikes
are happening right now
thanks laura i think um when we've got
an extraordinary situation i think
you mentioned in the in the presentation
that transport workers wherever they fit
rail
uh dock workers truck drivers
all did their part through the covey
period and now we're hit with enormous
levels of inflation
not seen for 40 years
and frankly people are extremely worried
about meeting their bills and their
commitments
at a time where there's clearly a void
of leadership in the politics in the uk
and no ready solution so all of the
cases you mentioned are actually
strikes voted on by the workers
themselves so i think the message to a
global audience is workers have had
enough they did their path through kovid
and now they recognize some extreme
increasing costs off the scale
and they're asking for a just and fair
equitable solution
pushpin do you do you agree with that
that workers that people the society at
large is facing extreme rising costs and
that this is an unworkable situation if
it continues as it is
for sure
like i mentioned before inflation is
almost
definitely at a 40-year high and is
spiraling out of control i think the
most recent uh gap data on earnings as
well shows real pay uh decreasing by
three percent uh compared to the last
year's quarter two and that gap uh
between inflation and uh earnings have
never been higher since records started
two decades ago so definitely uh a lot
of it is firing up spiraling out of
control and a lot must be done to help
households actually manage the bills and
actually survive this cost of living
crisis charles where is the government
in all of this there is a gap there
people workers are feeling that they use
strikes as last resorts they've tried to
negotiate
they don't feel they're getting anywhere
why not
i think it's very difficult you know we
are living through unprecedented times
you just had the government
offer uh you know unprecedented package
of intervention during covid we've got
to pay that money back they're just
trying to get the economy back on
on its feet now i've been hit by these
sort of 40-year high of inflation partly
fueled by the war in ukraine so to some
extent they are between a rock and a
hard place we're gonna have to pay for
this at some point um you know it is
affecting everybody across the board but
you know if they do i think giving to
these demands then you're gonna have
more pain down the line uh across the
board you know it's not just uh you know
the public sector workers people in the
private sector are uh are facing these
challenges as well um you know and there
isn't a coin a phrase a magic money tree
they can't just keep bailing everyone
out they've already uh put them put out
they're going to put out a i think it's
a 400 pound package for households hit
by the rising cost of energy in october
they've got also a number of one-off
payments for different um groups hit by
uh the surge in enterprises so it's very
difficult but i mean the politics of
this are i think at the moment
uh public sentiment is probably with uh
the government a lot of people can see
that you know they are you know we've
been going through these very difficult
difficult time so there is pain coming
down the track of course if this does
spread and we have this almost
unprecedented situation where you know
as we talked about the criminal
barristers could it hit the teachers are
the public sectors walking out then you
know it is a political a huge political
danger spot uh for the government
because at some point uh i suspect the
public's patience will run out
you raised a number of different points
there that i want to pick up on one of
them stephen giles saying public
sentiment is with the government at the
moment do you agree with that or do you
believe that you've got the support of
the general public
well i think um we probably move in
different circles if i'm frank the
reality is
most people are very very concerned
about meeting their bills so the public
sentiment certainly from our experience
with our affiliates unite rmt as left so
those are rail and and the felix strike
is that there's a lot of solidarity
and um you know
felix though has been one of the most
successful ports
the first strike in 30 years probably
says it all there's been very
responsible approach to industrial
action
and the reality is we you know the
ideological comment charles if i'll be
picking you up is give in to this i
think the reality is
people see so much wealth accumulated
in the top elements of our society and
we've heard all of these companies
taking share dividends
these are extreme sets of circumstances
the cost
of living is a 40-year high we need to
look at this in a different way
workers collaborated throughout the
pandemic to keep those that are in the
global supply chain to keep the world
moving
we think and we believe that the
transport workers and today's workers
should be shown the same level of
respect in a moment of crisis we should
be looking at how do we come up with
economic fiscal approach
to help distribute the wealth you cannot
um take so much money out of people's
pockets per month and not expect a
reaction so for us
all the feedback we have all the chat
rooms that we're party to have a look on
twitter there is a very strong sense of
injustice for people who feel that their
money's being taken out of their pocket
and they don't have any control over the
situation pushpin what do you think of
that do you agree that there is enough
money to go around that there is enough
money to combat this situation in the uk
right now but it's just concentrated in
the wrong places
uh i think
definitely it's going to tax a lot on
the government finances and the treasury
uh as mentioned before uh a lot of
spending was done during the covert to
help
a lot of workers a lot of key workers uh
a lot of workers were distressed during
code uh to get through those times
properly as part of the furlough team uh
pandemic support and whatsoever uh now
we are faced with unprecedented
inflationary environments where more
spending needs to be done uh
definitely it's gonna tax the treasury a
lot and there is
if there's gonna be handouts or tax cuts
either way it has to be financed by more
boring which already puts strain so is
there a lot of money going on frankly
not really but a lot of cost effective
and a lot of uh smart ways have to be
thought of by the next government in
terms of how this is going to be
properly promulgated and implemented to
help households i mean some some would
say that the conservatives are not
offering a solution that's a number of
reasons why people are saying the
conservatives are not offering solutions
not least the fact there's no clear
leadership at the moment but we'll get
on to that in just a moment but another
reason perhaps is that vast public
spending is simply not in the tory dna
and therefore
the conservatives find it very difficult
to
propose more money to be offered to
people
well i mean you're right they are
um low tax and they like less
intervention having said that you've had
one of the most interventious
governments
in recent history what's happening in
relation to covert as i said they've
intervened in terms of the energy price
uh surging energy prices but why it's
logically and fundamentally what we'll
see is if we do get a liz trust
premiership is they are against a winful
tax against the big oil companies they
think
uh in the in the long term it just
damages the investment environment puts
businesses off coming here what we need
is a low tax uh you know environment
which will attract businesses but also
we have to be smarter about our energy
sources about developing alternative
energy sources and the energy companies
have to think about how they can deliver
lower cost
um energy as well but i mean i come back
to my point before i think there has
been a lot of public spending this is
the problem there isn't unprecedented
taps
of cash in the reserves in the
government hugely
servicing huge levels of debt which have
high rates of interest so we're just
storing up more paying the long term
unfortunately there is no
uh there is no you know easy solution to
this and this is something which is not
just unique to the uk in terms of the
surging energy crisis this is something
which is hitting uh countries across
europe i mean it does underlie i think
you know one thing which has become
apparent is there's been too much
reliance on russia
for our energy uh
and now we're paying the price for that
uh push but charles says that there has
been intervention on the energy prices
and yet they are still rising aren't
they i mean they're still set to rise
this winter they've gone up from 1 200
on average last year to 3
400 pounds that's a huge rise for most
people
why
are they not why can it not happen that
the energy companies themselves are
forced to charge less that proper caps
are put on prices
you can't do that there's no there's no
say how in terms of what can be done
what can't be done the problem with that
is putting a cap on prices to protect
households yes it will definitely in in
terms of uh alleviating the cost to
households and especially lower income
households will definitely protect them
from paying the extras uh the slated
extra incentives later the rife is
supposed to happen in october and in
january as well where we can see energy
price kept increasing to upwards of five
thousand pounds i think the most recent
even came out is six thousand uh we saw
today but putting the price gap also
distorts uh putting a cap on the price
cap itself actually distorts price
signals uh by because by doing so in the
sense households and consumers uh won't
be kind of wary about how much the
energy bills are increasing and with the
same regular use that they're doing it
now uh doing as of now and without
seeing uh kind of changing energy prices
due to the cap it distorts a lot of
signals and adds a lot of fluctuations
and a lot adds a lot of
knock-on effects to the economy so that
has a very dangerous effect going
forwards as well so putting that cap is
not exactly feasible okay and stephen
some would say that the strikes have
knock-on effects to the economy as well
the critics would say that they cause a
wage price spiral of course where rising
wages would feed into this cycle of
inflation i think i think
as we've seen in the past
industrial relations before kovid
on many occasions have found a solution
that's been satisfactory both for for
private companies and for the government
the situation we have at the moment is a
feeling that people are actually losing
their purchasing power at the same time
of mass cost now i think
human nature
is such that i think particularly in the
uk a sense of what's fair and there's a
feeling at the moment that there are
still large dividends coming out of what
work for state-owned assets um including
some of the energy companies are making
enormous amounts of money for people
that are not able to put it back and
therefore the majority i think the study
is there's a number of studies but
citibank perceives that we could be as
high as um i think it's 14
at the end 12.2 12.2 by the end of the
year by 18.6 by january 2023 with these
numbers coming out
and workers feel they have no choice but
to stop
and as we've said the uk has got very
strong labor laws
that require very um
a big process of getting a majority to
win the right to strike what we're
seeing is immense support for these
strikes from the workers and i would
argue from from the society as a large
because i think you know and if we look
at the situation um p ferries where so
many workers were sacked and caused such
outrage there's a feeling that um big
business can do what it likes
and the government is kind of colluding
with the process so for for working men
and women the opportunity to withdraw
their labour is frankly the last stand
now we would actively through this
process not discourage business from
coming to the uk but also be in a
position to encourage people back to the
table
everybody wants security in their jobs
fought to pay the bills um and then be
in a position to go to work and and give
a give a give a performance i think if
we just touch on the rail strike that
feels very heavily politically motivated
um and this hire and fire strategy
that's been advocated by the transport
minister is aggravating the situation if
we were dealing with just cost issues
and a recognition that we've got an
unprecedented post coving situation a
40-year high in costs let's get back to
negotiating and let's find a solution
of course um
you know when the bank of england comes
out and says
workers shouldn't ask for pay rises i
think that doesn't reflect the reality
of the men and women in the uk and not
just the uk as as joel said the the
rising cost is extremely high but the uk
has one of the freest markets and with
no caps
or caps being withdrawn or running out
we're seeing a moment where people
are very scared and you know let's just
look at
the issue of
barristers criminal barristers they are
not the worst paid workers in the world
even they're coming out on strike so i
think we need to how we deal with this
we need to find a constructive way to
negotiate we would encourage employers
government to sit down recognize that
this is an unprecedented moment that
solutions and confidence in workers and
the businesses they work for is vital
okay and not get
a launch strike let's just let giles
pick up that um stephen's saying people
are scared this is an unprecedented
moment
where's the government in all this
where's the leadership we're seeing
boris johnson the prime minister on his
second holiday of the summer he seems to
have signed off and just passed on all
of this to whoever takes over that's not
happening until september the 5th
there's going to be a lot of damage
potentially done between now and then
we're not seeing any policies announced
by the two prospective candidates do you
feel that there is a would you agree
there is a lack of leadership i think
you're right there is a vacuum and it is
a dangerous spot for a conservative
party to some extent the problem facing
boris johnson is because he's going to
be out of number 10 in two weeks it's
probably it's not morally responsible to
be taking decisions which the next prime
minister then has to take on so there's
a sense of trying to do the right thing
and defer things on but to your point
we've got a situation which could start
moving at breakneck speed and it is a
danger point now let's work on the
assumption that if the poles are right
we're going to have a liz trust
premiership it's something that she's
going to need to get to grips to very
quickly because if this does start
spreading out a lot more i mean we use
the sort of standard
uh sort of underground rail strikes
boston annually but as it starts
spreading out if it does start spreading
out you know criminal barristers then
you may see public patients uh the
public lose their patience
and you know then the government is
going to be in a real danger spot
because whatever the rights and the
wrongs of the situation politically
people will at that point i think if it
does happen
start to blame the governments they're
going to need to find and come in
with some kind of solution or some kind
of way to break the deadlock
and the impacts you know i think
historically often when these strikes
have been confined to the rail network
people are you know it hasn't really
damaged the government's stature and
standing but this has the potential to
be very different and certainly
unprecedented during my my lifetime i
think in relation to the rail sets a lot
of people sort of say well you know your
people say this is just going to
accelerate the movement towards more
automation driverless trains obviously
all the people were working from home
during covid so they sort of said well i
can take the one on strikes but if it
does spread and becomes a normal then
yeah
incredibly problematic with all the
other backdrops the uk looking like it's
heading into recession cost living
crisis it could be the perfect storm for
the new prime minister
uh and be a gift to labour party
absolutely pushpin what sort of solution
do you think england britain needs
definitely a lot more targeted solutions
in terms of what can be done and what
can be known to at least alleviate the
cost of main crisis uh what uh what was
said before about the perfect storm is
definitely a perfect description what's
happening to the uk right now in terms
of uh external factors concerning supply
side shocks including the war in ukraine
you've got rising energy prices
previously
and initially due to a kind of
suppressed supply
uh and now due again to energy commodity
inflation and on top of that it could
cause a living crisis as well and uh
that is going to be followed with
economic downturn as we can see through
q2's figures we saw 0.1 contraction and
it's very likely that the uk is going to
recession uh and i think the priority
should be to be helping households and
lower income as especially lower income
households in terms of trying to deal
with this whole idea of this whole
phenomenon of a downturn along with
starting prices uh and definitely uh i
uh there's a lot of things coming into
play right now in terms of how you can't
just stop five signals at the same time
helping households while at the same
time once more uh managing the books
which is what the ex-transfer actually
did uh was trying to do as part of his
primary uh motivations uh a lot of
targeted handouts would be required and
a lot of effective and timely measures
have to be are required as well but uh
clearly that's not the case right now
given the whole idea of a vacuum and we
still have yet to see who's yet uh to
come into the hot seat in two weeks but
yeah absolutely i mean that would be a
big
point as well stephen just lastly
what happens if these strikes don't
bring about the pay rises that workers
are demanding
well i think there's a feeling certainly
across
all sectors in the uk labor movement
that cooperation and collaboration
about what the message is and what the
challenges are so i think we're going to
see
more challenges when it comes to workers
voting for strike action until we start
to see some constructive settlements
these issues about um
and of course the rail strike gets the
the biggest profile but there's a lot in
that package it's not just money it's
about changing the way
the rail industry works i think we need
to get um people
back into into moving and transport is
critical
i think the situation which we've seen
is
in the private sector lots of lots of of
really big returns in the container
markets in the supply chain but let's
not forget supply chain is driven by
demand and if you don't give people
money to spend and they're worried about
one their jobs and meeting their bills
how we're going to drive the economies
we perceive that there will be a
recession and again we'll need to drive
out of that so i think
unions workers i certainly feel and
let's be clear this rail strike is far
from over um there is a solidarity
across different categories of workers
and as i say it's unprecedented we're
going to have to leave it there
apologies for jumping in there stephen
but uh we are going to have to leave it
there and many thanks for joining us to
all of our guests today stephen cotton
pushpin singh and giles cunningham and
thank you too for watching you can see
the program again anytime by visiting
our website aljazeera.com
and for further discussion do go to our
facebook page that's
facebook.comajinsidestory
and you can also join the conversation
on twitter we are at aj inside story
from me laura kyle and the whole team
here it's bye for now
you